you
maybe we could play some an hourly
crazy-house arena I don't know if I'll
them do the whole thing but these are
always so much fun
hourly crazy house arena here let me
link it if you want to jump in there's
only 13 in there right now flyer it has
been a while it's been like six years
now since I played OTV tournaments so
there's the link link it once more let's
do a little crazy house alright let's
let's be a monster let's try to be as
direct as possible so this is three Oh
time control I'm just doing a little bit
of crazy house since I streamed last
um what is that in the chat thank you
whoa
one two three thank you for the $75
donation you also add for the YouTube
videos and the free lesson at least
where it's one hour lessons thank you
thank you so much for that man Wow
that is a very generous donation thank
you so much for that you are awesome Wow
all right let's
[Music]
throw some pieces out there man I could
buy a lot of granola bars now yeah okay
what do we do you just take a night show
another one in there and be happy
maybe I should secure this first no no
no no we go on the offensive
straightaway Bishop their concerns right
now let's go here to protected square
you can pin my night bishop here is
probably pretty good but I just want to
take this guy and invite the King
forward and go from there
of days fun who knows if that's good or
not
Red Bull six-pack 12-hour stream Red
Bull is not for me no way this is stream
sniper
what
so here this mic and actually I didn't
have to do that but okay yeah you know
here's another thing
chop-chop I don't know
chop-chop and then the night drop here
follow
let's castle all right my king is cozy
and I'm dropping this night they can
take twice okay but come on you could
start some trouble right
let's go to Bishop here
your squares
let us see here
yes crazy house if you're new to it my
opponent on any open square here can
drop their knight and on any open square
between these two ranks inclusive they
could drop upon
they have one
in one night they can put on any open
square basically and where I just have a
slight time I don't take with them let's
take with the night and then drop him in
here I like converging on intersection
squares are a big thing of crazy house
keying in on squares around the enemy
King actually you know what I should do
behavior never promote to clean the
plenty of cases where you want to
promote to a night with check initiative
initiative initiative so let's start an
initiative right now this is very likely
a bad idea why did it not pick that I
don't know yeah
they believe me so the night then I was
prepared to take a pond and then put up
on here I don't know if that was any
good but and is my attempt to complicate
if you're promoted
captured to return is a pond yeah let's
take this night I got a bishop now and
okay there's got to be something juicy
huh
now let's just take a pond and get here
that move let's go here they're way down
on time
on takes fun I have a bishop trap here
okay
so now you start in some trouble here
I'll just scoot out the way now if there
is a queen there would be a clean drop
here and then a knight smothered bank
okay so let's let's start going after my
opponent there's nothing good that they
have let's just take the Queen I got a
clean now stop a rook let's just take
stuff they're playing very fast I should
have a mate that mate
it's me back to tournament lands
alrighty I gained two points for that
the hourly crazy-house arena there are
now 44 in here Sun dragon all right oh
yeah let's let's just bring the night up
maybe in some cases I go Bishop to b5
Who am I kidding it's pointing right at
the weakest Square look Castle first
always a little bit concern that there's
this and my King gets lured out so this
is like the same opening should I be
dropping the bishop back here
[Music]
this is a pretty common
give up the Queen I'm still going to do
it I'm not going to take the Queen
though I might be losing a piece with
this variation but I like that I'm in
the end I'm on move let's see what a
black does so I believe we could take
here and if I recapture go here and then
I'm like down a piece which is really
like two pieces for a crazy house if you
lose up one pawn it's really like to so
yeah well for right now at least I have
I don't have to recapture there's many
different captures here so let's
consider could do a knight drop here or
actually now we're going to take here
we're going to do a knight drop there
let's see what my opponent does oh you
know what is you know what I should have
done to put a knight here so I had a
queen drop and then a knight takes here
I want a knight h6 is better maybe I
could set that up somehow
should I take here hmm I have two nights
here I think I need some security over
here I'm going to drop my queen and try
to mate and just cover some stuff around
my King for like night checks this is so
there's so much stuff that could be
captured in this position so I like that
first to generate some threat cleaned is
a pretty good defensive job and it's a
nice move so yeah can I find a safe
square for my queen I got here there's a
night job
like like queen is ready to be captured
with check I see all right well let's
also if I go there there's a night drop
here holy cow my claims gonna die huh I
don't have much time where do you go oh
brother
I don't know I don't want to I guess I'm
just have to allow that
you
take like and I don't know they could do
a night drop at night here I can't give
them a night otherwise there's a night
drop at night here some other great
night drop takes night here so if they
take here fortunately I could take and
give a check King in the corner it may
be a pretty good spot because there's
only two ways a night could be dropped
and you know there's only two night
drops that can be I could get check yeah
there's that move I don't know let's
keep up
I don't know oh well look at my time
they're ready to do that night drop
stuff I got a I got to defend this
square I don't know how to do it yeah
I'm so dead I'll let them show you how
to do it night drop or a queen drop in
the night here
and they wear that yep back to
drawing board on that one I guess that's
just not a good line now that isn't the
whole story there were so many different
moves I think I would have tried Knight
h6 instead that's a pretty odd move to
see I'm pretty sure we can go with
Fisher's advice for crazy house efore
best buy test I think so what's that
just treat some three check crazy house
variance clean is on a rampage against
Yoshii Pro where's the mate drop on
there let's keep up the checks
yeah where are you going
where do you think you're going
check they don't
the block with just keep checking grab a
pawn with check make a block that's me
that was a weird game on the world is
the Yoshi Pro doin bishop or a pawn drop
on d2 that was a freebie I will take
that fun alright so who's in first here
9 is in first I'm in there for already
oh this guy is very close and rating so
let's see we're not going to try that
piling up on the pin again try it's open
different cover up to first I'll still
come out to Bishop g5 but to do
something different okay well let's look
just back up for a moment let's keep the
pin and yeah I'll do this I'm going to
take and drop in here here here
Knight there clean over we're going to
find out
these tricky night drops
I suggest we return my queen can I go
crazy and just take here I feel like I
just want to do that let's do it take a
night and then chip away at f6 you know
I think this is good actually I strike
first at the King position the same
freaking so looking to just now to
hammer away at f6 Knight here Knight
here I would prefer to have this Knight
drift a little bit towards the Kings
side so this kind of stuff a knight drop
there so what I going to do
okay so just hop right in is there
something more forceful it better to
throw a knight on board maybe it is
actually yeah you know let's put a
knight here right now
maybe not lift
involved I'm leaving myself open for
and I have to take otherwise I get
mating on each - I have to do this I'm
just getting mated where's the mate
false sense of danger alert Oh Knight f3
I didn't see it coming
not even close
ah man ah that was a forced mate that
was a forced mate sequence right there
hmm
okay okay okay still a rookie still
rookie a big stop I'm still a rookie all
right I like having my pawns promoted I
don't mean like promoted on the back
rank I mean like I like to be able to
recapture with my pawns and drift
towards their king improve my pawns yes
and my rook
and if I need them okay how can we hurt
my opponent how they feel about a bishop
here let's find out maybe here is better
good block with the bishop but I insist
he's back for more and we're gonna have
a clean shop of clean cakes come on you
know you want to do it
maintain your structure don't take with
the fun all right
well I probably need some more pieces in
font Oh
well
what do I do here throw a knight here
what can I put that bishop that's good
all right you know all right we're going
to do something like this
it's bad but I don't know I want to
starve some trouble near the king
maybe I drop a pawn here one day I like
to see the pawns moved from these a
second-rank squares so when you do a
pawn drop here it's usually a pretty
devastating thing to your opponent
let's see what light comes up with there
there's thinking this tree I got another
pond it's ready to rumble ah that would
have been a cry let's see I could do
here now let's go here let's keep on
throwing punches
ona has two bishops and upon
one minute for team light no income in
here already let's take and I need some
more fuel and let's go here I want to
drop something on the F 3 square
controlling two holes here and now I
need some more fuel so I'll be able to
take something out clean check I can
block with the night take this night
draw night in here and lay down on time
ok let's ignore their threat from my
night into f3 22 seconds
[Music]
I guess we'll just block like this I
don't want to give this square up to a
night all right let's jump in you know
what I want to do I want to eliminate
this night he's covering this square I
want to have that one open and how about
we start with the check
and I need more fuel let's take this guy
I'm giving my opponent a lot of material
I got a bishop time on the Queen here we
go keep on going under ten seconds
I got a queen though should I throw her
in the mix right now
um yeah why not let's go here let's go
here give me something to work with
I got a pond how many time though yeah I
don't know that was pretty squared
pretty square II had quad Knights
quad Knights and a few bishops ah my
apologies to those who may be watching
who are experienced crazy house players
I'm sure you are saying to yourself man
if he ever tried that against me I would
smash him high now man I know I'm still
learning still learning
dragon 96 is in there he's gained 510
points Wow ditch 24 thank you for the 17
months in a row man appreciate the
support
another III so the three best buy test
is efore strong pawn Center
Space Invader let's give a check try to
induce this guy because I might want to
drop something here one day give me a
file for my rope give me I like being in
a position where one of my pieces can
capture there's but not the other way
around
all right I got a bishop now so I might
want to go over in this area you know
like what about here because it's
pointing towards squares near their King
and it doesn't allow one day for one of
their pieces to drop over here
now let's key in on these squares
can i play up three Oh
I'll take him first there's no fancy
where the night checks feast through the
night checks you just grabbed upon take
your night
I'll take the night how do you feel
right around this point there might be
Queen takes Knight here Bishop here mate
it's close this is really close takes
takes night drop on G for the King goes
to G one Bishop drop here is mate the
King has to go here Bishop drops still
King has to go they're just going to do
it I should have something good here
come on what am i doing I can take my
bishop oh that's okay now he's he's
lured out he's lured out so much for
that calculation I forgot them there's a
disconnect okay come on you're
surrounded King you are surrounded
no what about this pick up upon a pawn
drop right here for Nate maybe a bishop
here what do they have in the
counter-attack I got this covered I
don't want to expose my king to checks I
don't want to expose my king to checks
on the back rank what's this spout I can
just take that night there's no Queen
check over here
there's no pawn checks and now I have a
healthy group of pieces in my pocket
already
I have everything controlled around the
King so they're in trouble
paunchy did the trick that's mate Bishop
would have done it as well we got eight
27 minutes left on page 264 players in
this one already
what's up st. Lucas in the chat hello to
you alright
des Moines on board another e4 e5 game I
should be getting better positions the
white side here come up with something
better
alright I still think that this is
correct hang on that's a little
different
Thank You striker for the 18 months in a
row appreciate the support
[Music]
let's tin the night
and now it's time to key in on something
so they're keying in on this pond here
but this is a good move that defends
what they're doing and also more
what is that move about Oh what's going
on here
I have like a mating sequence now don't
I check check
what are they doing man they've gone
bananas take the clean hanging on may 1
million won a meenie miney moe
I have no idea why my what was that
Bishop d4 move can't make sense of that
all right I got 12 top guys lived up
okay this is a guy yeah this is the one
that uh he hit me with a combination I
just here we got with this you see he's
all booked up and stuff
he's all booked up
turning mastitis is that what's
happening here
somebody tell me did I already miss play
it am I already on the ropes and I just
don't realize it yet I'm I'm too stupid
to realize I'm still too too much of a
bunny for crazy house is that what's
happening here rattling off these moves
so fast
d6 yeah don't even spend some time
taking that pawn I'll take them all
right show you're not look at this
I'll see your what is that what's going
on
well what if I just take some stuff I'll
take some more stuff okay okay okay
now now maybe I defend a little bit
squares not that one I have a night job
here I could take it potentially and
then take the clean who knows how to
assess this position I see suppose I
ignore what you want to do and just play
extreme bad a move is about this is such
a wacky variant man
so wacky
and back a minute
Wow the lender man one is in first
Shelton to 308 is in second I'm back
here in sixth place land
what's up fish face in the chat could I
just take the night
you know I know
I need the Quinn I need to clean
already I think I have the employ
Square is covered okay just take the
night oh I don't know I don't know I
don't know how about we go into I don't
know
let's go here take that night
they have a clue
Bishop how are they going to hurt me who
giving me that
tonight here
I got another one we know how dangerous
they could be Knight f3 who's scared now
I have a pawn that's a super defender
give me a check he will block rest there
thank you for the sub with twitch Prime
I appreciate the support thank you a
check lock it upon
oh I could have just gotten here I was
thinking but both of the queens you know
is silly
let's try that let's try that what a
position defense defense
pawn drop here all right clean here you
know how many nights down to the wire
come on
let's go here hmm take that night a
night drop in there take that let's give
a check need a little defense
okay nights yes time burning drops baby
time burning pocket drops
who else is saying that right now who
else can decode that line then you guys
right here time burning pocket droppers
yeah
dropping those pieces from my pocket
burning time like a champion oh yeah
this in English who plays the English
normos Gorman's plays the English I
don't know is this any good feels like
there's a lot of gaps right here like oh
and I got a bishop I want to put them
here look at these gaps I don't care
about my bishop I just don't care about
him we're going to put this guy here
maybe take the rook maybe take the
knight maybe take the Queen one day
let's take the knight one of these two
right here sky here take here here it's
got to be something juicy ah give me
some pieces how can I can I get some
pieces even upon here let's do this
and then put upon here there we go now
we can take something with check what I
want to take one of these to this guy
let's take here he
down the ropes let's go here move a
night with discovery Bishop here alright
this King has he's running for his life
can I say put something in the way so I
could take it there we go maybe we start
with a check here
I wanna see them capture take care with
check I got another pond let's go with
here check see running away and there's
another check that the fork could take
him take him
let's take the one word switch check now
what had games flip away like this
before it's not fun it's not fun let's
go here put a pond here one day or a
night here I could have done that I
should have should have kept up
the initiative now that I can maybe stir
up some trouble I'm back on move is
check there we go I get to clean there
we go
where's the mate there it is
back to tournament all right we got 20
with fire four back from first
blunder man 1 still in the first
position 72 players in this one
fifteen minutes left
and this tournament flies by crazy house
am I gonna get a pairing wonder man
how's blender man doing okay
Shelton all right this guy's in second
there's a big tie here for second place
land let's still go with Bishop c4
Castle
support him first maybe I come out here
before this I don't know what the
difference is back to the same position
hm
alright well let's take and now
immediately chip away at this square
summer
positions if Bishop takes Knight I don't
know I mean there might be enough act
like right now I don't know that it's
even worth the time to recapture here in
fact I'm almost certain it's not or it's
the time to do that I should be going
here
like keeping the
night here okay so I'm definitely taking
the clean I don't see anything better
that is with check the do you have three
nights already so like a drop a night
here with check
[Music]
is that unnecessary can I just I don't
know like I don't even need to take that
can I just bring this clean out they're
going to repair their structure soon
with the bishop
oh just plant a knight right here let's
do that
trending mate trying to win upon put a
bishop here but then if I ever get
another night that would be may seems a
long way off now for me getting a night
one night on
they have three in the pocket I could
take this pawn with check let's do that
they go here I could come back with
check I like having a pond maybe a pond
drop here actually yeah it looks pretty
good
yeah that's getting pretty serious here
let's just consider some more forcing
respond drop clean drop pond drop right
here picking up the rook I don't think
they could do too much with the Knights
we're going to find out that huh
I could take I could not take I may not
even want to take not even going to take
but I would prefer to just keep this as
is I'll pick him up if I need them later
I have two pieces three pieces are
hanging I have a pond I could take I
have a clean I could still drop we
taking this rook with check right now
the threat is to take the rook with
check and then a clean drop here
all right so they're defending stuff
I'll fight on much time holy cow all
right let's go here first and let's
still insist down on and trying to get
rid of their back rank and Nate can
really see down ah I fell for this
smothered mate again ah that's Kitty
chest man
kitty Ches um and that is such a basic
crazy-house tactic that's twice twice
well I mean the first time it happened
in the tournament I knew it was coming I
was totally blind to it just then the
Kitty Ches Kay I didi why kitty Ches I
got that from a friend of mine either
when when something when you miss
something simple he'd say that's just
kitty Ches kitty it's like chess for
kids chess 101 oh man ah I was too
focused on what I want to do I maybe I
should just capture the night when it
was on h3 yeah there's a there note to
self
note to self you wanna you want to be
fancy and just throw your King in the
corner like that and say nah keep my
structure you set yourself up for that
little smother tactic you deserve to
lose that no one else to blame but
yourself
all right so this is this is tough to
break down we're going to try now
we're going to try shop
hmm
a good job of stopping some drop here
that's what I was one and that's what I
wanted to do all right let's see what
you do here I'm going to take care oh
yeah
that I'm a defending machine now mmm
let's go here let's go here let's try
that see what happens
see what happens I was thinking they're
going to drop upon here after I did the
recapture
or I want to take take the rickwaa check
the bishop let's check drop a bishop
let's check what do you do and you don't
know you want to do let's take the rook
try to get to their back rank one day
all right here's the plan
take this pawn and then put upon here
[Music]
what I could also do is simply take a
bishop and then maybe Nate already the
scholars made my opponent boom-boom
game over by regular chess means
probably put a pond somewhere to defend
on here on there and there it is
don't give up though don't you quit all
right let's put a rope right there
you
and put a knight here
no idea where
jack is going probably nowhere they have
three pawns are looking to night put a
rook here I feel like I just want to
take that night let's do it and find out
how bad it is
let's take here I'm going to get made
all right let's see if I can wear
some storm they're going to trial rook
here and my king will be running for his
life soon a couple different main
threats show me show me how it's done
man I'm going to block with a bishop
when I have if I'm going to block with a
piece I'd rather go with the bishop than
the knight back here because I want I
want to blend I want a knight and a
bishop
so look here Queen here we go bishop f1
and not consider that move so
fortunately okay yeah if you take here I
could take what's check
I'll get Lou it out that's kind of scary
Oh seventeen seconds run King
I'm slipping away he's a slippery King
he's slippery on top one here rook here
rook they're slippery King
Shayne bolt towards the queenside less
than 40
I shouldn't ever
suffice it he may survive it though
folks
less than 30 he doesn't see a win
run it's desperation huh counterpunch no
right here I don't want to wreck Rock
rook and droplets check no no no don't
leave me
yes there's no good move Oh No
time
they did to me what I did to that one
upon the pocket drop time burner
technique
they got me oh look at this oh man I
have a lot to learn a lot to learn I
need to play what increment I need
increment I prefer and commit
Adam I had him but he probably had me
first his attack was the front and out
his attack was running out of steam and
so is my clock that was a big problem
one of the big problems okay let's put a
night here all right
going to be the last game let's see what
happens the hot pocket technique micron
in the chat is pointing out they
probably have something a now and I'm
almost certain they just had you know my
King was lured out I don't know some of
the some of the critical squares I was
covering though let's just pick up on
caveman attack caveman attack
all righty let's see see what to do here
I don't even know what I'm trending yeah
what do I do now I have to hope that I
get some of their pieces one day fishing
for
move traps maybe we pick a ruck up
against the lazy guys 25 seconds
tournament clock make it one
I'll take them check
check where you goin King what are you
so scared of what are you so scared of I
want a piece they have a queen too
but I'm out of gas then
we're going to get made on each to put a
bishop here clean drop bishop here
Bishop their Queen h2 Queen f2 no I mean
they could just foil all my plans throw
up on here here here Queen check on
check Bishop check so much so much a
fairy and seven says I really enjoy your
YouTube channel just discovered your
stream where you been man the stream has
been around for quite some time
glad you can make it a boatload of
material for my opponent they have a
nice pocket some interesting games this
tournament
always a blast they're not okay so
that's how they're going to defend but I
could take on Poisson you can also drop
a queen and then take and then drop upon
here let's try it out trending trending
like a million tree Queen drop pond drop
pond takes
discover check let's see
check
remove that take that let's check
where's the make don't run out of time
in don't run out of time they're able to
defend get over here man
don't run away on me run away on me man
oh no run out there no yes they're done
time just before they can make me wow
what an end a crazy house is that's the
perfect name whoo oh my goodness I had
so much to learn
hit the hate the crazy house books all
right
82 in the end gee
good games all that is such a fun
variant gotta love the crazy house
[Music]